I want to get busy on the first couple
of subjects for today.
Everybody that's okay.
Say I'm okay.
Here's the first subject that I've found
so interesting.
I want to share it with you.
Then I want to talk about personal
development of the subject that I
started listening to age 25.
That revolutionized my whole life from
my mentor,
Mr Earl shoaff.
Here's an interesting subject.
Just jot it down.
Now.
It's called enlightened self interest,
enlightened self interest.
It's a fascinating study to study the
idea of self interest,
but just make this note,
all of us,
you know,
have self-interest.
Key is for it to be enlightened so that
everybody wins and no one loses.
Our first interest is to survive.
What does it take to survive?
Our second interest is to succeed.
What does it take to succeed?
What does it take for me personally to
survive and to succeed?
Can I legitimately be interested enough
in the things that helped me both
succeed and survive,
and here's what I discovered.
The answer is yes.
It's possible to exercise self interest,
but to do it in such a way that no one
loses everyone benefits.
Keyphrase life was not designed to give
us what we need.
Life was designed to give us what we
deserve.
We did not reap a harvest in the fall
because we need it.
We reap a harvest in the fall because we
deserve it.
Not necessarily from a moral standpoint.
Of course,
of course,
there are some moral laws as well,
spiritual and moral laws,
but just the basic laws that simply say,
if you wish to read,
you must plant,
so jot this down.
Reaping is reserved for the planters
and the reason they reap is because they
deserve it.
They're the planters they deserved to
read.
Interesting Bible phrase that says,
if you keep knocking,
you will find open doors.
Good phrase to jot down.
If you keep knocking,
you will find open doors,
doors of opportunity.
Doors have a chance to meet someone.
Doors open for association doors.
Open to find someone special doors open
to find a unique business colleague.
If you keep knocking the door,
the phrase says,
doors of opportunity are open to those
who continually knocked,
so we don't find open doors of
opportunity because we need.
We find them because we deserved only
those who knock deserve to find an open,
but the promise is if you continually
knock,
you'll find doors of opportunity.
It says,
if you search,
you will find
so I'll make the note.
It's good finding is reserved for the
searchers
because they deserve it.
Now,
at first they may have needed it,
but they now know that just needing it
is not sufficient.
If they need it now,
they must qualify for it.
The reason why you're going to be
blessed with good ideas this weekend is
because you've come searching,
gotten on an airplane to come searching.
Got It in your automobile to come
searching.
You got here searching.
Now you're ready to receive,
and for those who have search,
they will find answers.
They will find plans,
imagination to stir yourself into action
for future benefit.
So if you search to find a good idea,
you'll go looking,
searching.
You've got to go to church,
you've got to go to class,
you've got to go to the seminar,
you've got to go to the library.
You've got to go to the books.
If you wish to find,
rarely does a good idea,
interrupt you
rarely,
but if you will search,
you will find it so we get not what we
need,
but we get what we deserve.
It's just if you ask,
someone has an answer,
if you keep asking,
the answers belong to you because by
virtue of asking,
you have qualified so we don't get what
we need.
We get what we deserve.
The mother on welfare should be taught
in some small.
Enter the.
Hopefully she can begin deserving the
welfare kid,
not getting it because she needs it now,
starting to get it because she deserves
it.
If the welfare worker says to Mary,
Mary,
I brought a bucket of paint and a paint
brush,
and the next time I come,
if the door is painted in the fence here
in front is painted,
I give you the check for $450.
Not the painting,
the door and painting the fence is worth
$450.
It's not worth that much,
but it is the beginning of the process.
So make that note.
I want to begin the process of
deserving.
What would that be?
What process should I begin engaging in
to deserve good health,
to deserve a good relationship,
to deserve prosperity,
to deserve an enterprise,
to deserve the opportunity to build the
city
must I do to begin the process of
deserved
so now the welfare worker comes back and
the door is painted in the fences
painted and now Mary gets the $450 to
help take care of her children.
Not because she needs it,
but because she's beginning to deserve
it and the welfare worker thinks of some
other project.
She said,
Mary,
if these weeds are gone and this little
garden has cultivated when I come back,
now that the door is painted and the
fence is paid it,
if the weeds are gone and this little
garden has cultivated,
you get the $450 and step by step.
A new life is emerging.
Learning the process of deserving it,
not just
we teach our children at home,
right?
Child says,
I need $10 so that language doesn't work
here.
There's plenty of money here and the
vaults are full,
but to say I need $10 is not how you
open the vault.
So the channel says,
what?
Wow,
how can I get that $10 that I need?
So here's what they learned to say,
how could I earn $10?
Now the vault opens up.
Now the money starts to flow.
How can I earn $10?
What could I do to earn the money?
Not to get the money because you need
it,
but if you maybe you need the money.
That's all of us have needs here.
The key is to figure out how to open the
vault,
how to open the bank,
how to open this unbelievable flow of
resources to come our way and here's the
key to deserve it,
not to need it.
You can't walk out to the field and say
to the field,
I need to crop.
Here's what the field says.
Here's what the ground says.
Who is this clown that brings me his
need but brings me no seed,
so jot that down.
Take your seed to the marketplace,
not your need.
Don't disclose your need to the
marketplace,
only your willingness.
We'll talk about that a little later
today
because the marketplace is not
interested in your knee,
but they are interested in your seed.
They're interested in your willingness
to work.
They're interested in your disciplines.
They're interested in your eagerness.
They're interested in your vitality and
your work ethic.
That's what the marketplace is
interested in,
not your need that you're seed.
Okay?
We get what we deserve.
Old Testament.
God says,
if you'll move toward me,
I'll move toward you.
See,
that's how you get those occasions to
meet God.
You must make the move.
God could say you don't move.
I don't move.
You say,
well,
that's arbitrary.
Well,
when you're God,
you can make it that way.
So
the law says,
if you wish to receive.
Now let's talk about enlightened self
interest.
If you wish to receive,
and we would call the wish to receive
self interest,
but if it's enlightened,
self interest.
Here's what it says.
I understand that in order to receive,
I must view
receiving is reserved for those who
give.
Receiving is not reserved for those who
need it.
It's reserved for those who deserve it.
We deserve the receiving,
giving.
In fact,
there's an extraordinary phrase in just
a little context and here's what it is.
It's better to give
than it is to receive.
Now the uneducated person would find
that difficult to ponder.
Why would it be better to give than it
is to receive?
So let me give you one of the better
phrases for the day.
Here it is.
Giving starts the receiving process.
Yes,
so of course it's better.
Yeah,
it is.
How much receiving do you wish you must
start?
The giving process
for me to receive my additional fortunes
for the future,
not necessarily for the money because I
don't need them.
I take them up.
I don't need them,
but here's what I do need for someone to
say,
a year from now,
five years from now,
Mr Ryland net seminar helped to change
my life and for whatever reason,
I was brought here to this place for
this time and later someone says that
seat to receive that kind of thinks.
It's unbelievable.
Here's what you cannot buy,
that kind of thing.
You can't buy it with money.
You have to earn it.
Now,
let's expand a little further now that
it's called the law of riches and wealth
in our own self interest.
If we wish to be rich and wealthy and
prosperous and healthy and all the
valuable things we can think of for the
human experience,
how could we get there?
It's understanding the law of
enlightened self interest in the law of
deserving.
The question was asked in the Bible,
how can we be great?
What is the key to greatness?
Great Wealth,
great return,
great accolades,
trophies to put on the mantle above the
fireplace.
How can we get great respect?
Great Richard's great abundance for
ourselves.
How can we get that?
And the answer was given,
and here was the answer.
Find a way to serve.
Find a way to serve the mini.
So I paraphrase it.
To read this service.
Too many leads to greatness,
service.
Too many leads to greatness.
Someone says,
well,
about the best I can do is take care of
myself.
That's okay.
Self care has its own reward,
but it's very limited.
Let me.
It says,
I can't be worried about other people's
problems.
I got enough problems of my own.
That's okay.
Self defense is okay.
Self preservation is okay,
but it has a very limited reward.
If you wish to change that into
abundance,
prosperity,
and uniqueness,
then here's what you must do.
Help solve other people's problems.
Help finances for someone else,
not just for yourself,
but for someone else.
And in that kind of service,
you now begin the process of grief.
Someone asked the question,
how can I be ruler over many?
How could I manage a lot of people?
How could I be the leader of a vast
movement or enterprise?
Here was the answer.
Nothing wrong with that,
which we call that self interest of the
highest kind wishing to be the manager,
the ruler bushing to be presiding over
many people.
Here was the answer.
Be Faithful when the amounts are small.
Be Faithful when there's just a few.
Be disciplined when there's only a few
that starts to entitle you to someday be
ruler over many.
You say,
well,
if I had a big organization,
you know,
I'd really run it with a strong hand and
I'd be a fabulous leader,
but I've only got a few and I don't know
where they are.
See that that's not gonna work.
If you wish to preside over Richard,
so you must start with the amounts are
small.
Someone says,
Oh,
if I had a fortune,
I'd really take good care of it,
but I've only got a paycheck.
I don't know where it goes.
See not knowing where it goes,
disqualifies you now for presiding over
the fortune.
We've all heard that,
right?
I don't know where it all goes.
Do you ever hear that expression or we'd
love to have you run the company.
You don't know where it all goes.
Somebody says,
it just gets away from me.
Oh,
we'd love to have you run the world,
right?
It just gets away from you.
Somebody says it's only pennies and it's
only a few.
Here is where you begin to qualify for
abundance and riches and greatness and
respect is to be disciplined when the
amounts are small.
Someone finds it unique,
right?
That this many people would come here.
What I've got to say for the whole
weekend,
but this is not where I started.
I started with just a few,
but I was so unfamiliar with the few
trying to translate for them in my
awkward ways back then what had happened
to me.
My life got changed,
my income got changed,
my health got changed,
everything got changed for the better,
and now I've lived the most
extraordinary life,
but it started with my passion for just
a few to translate for just the few.
Someone says,
well,
they're just a few here.
You know,
does this meeting matter when there's
only a few in?
The answer's yes,
jot this down.
You never know who's in the audience,
whether it's a few or a thousand or
whatever,
but you got to be faithful when there's
just a few.
Tell your story when there's just a few.
Be just as passionate about ideas that
can change someone's life when there's
just a few.
Now you begin.
You're not fully qualified,
but you begin the qualification to
someday speak to many someday preside
over a vast crowd.
Someday be the manager or the leader of
millions.
It starts in those early days to deserve
it.
Now,
jot this down.
Also,
give yourself a chance to change some
things.
I held onto that.
I thought this was it.
This was it.
I'm telling you.
After a while,
I gave it up.
Found out it wasn't there,
so give yourself a chance to change.
Refine your philosophy,
refine your direction.
If you'll give yourself a chance to do
that,
here's what will happen down the road.
A ways a new door will open that you
haven't discovered before.
Give yourself a chance to change.
Re-Evaluate,
okay,
so let your library the testimonial of
your dedicated interest in accelerated
personal development that you will read
whatever you have to read,
you will hear whatever you must hear and
you will watch and see whatever you must
see in order to make your life refined
and worthwhile and achieve all of your
purposes.
That's what I want this stopping station
to be these three days just to come here
and sit for a while and listen and
ponder and take notes and work hard and
see if you can't absorb,
get all that you possibly can here so
that it will start to refine your life
even before you get on an airplane and
fly back to wherever you came from
before you get into your car and drive
away what we share with you here with
whatever all the rest that you've
learned.
This will be a catalyst to start a
process.
Even before you get home,
they'll start working for you.
Some of you are going to set some goals.
We're going to do the workshop tomorrow,
designing the next 10 years.
Hopefully you'll come up with some new
promises,
some new objectives,
some new ideas,
and by the time we're finished here,
these two,
three days,
I'm telling you,
you'll see yourself able to accomplish
two times,
three times,
five times more than you ever thought
was possible,
which will make this cost of this
seminar small price to pay,
and hopefully it'll make the time you
spent here small price to pay compared
to making this an investment in your
future and what will flow in,
in terms of money and income and return
and reward and respect and dignity and
accolades,
trophies,
all the stuff that can be yours,
a marriage that lasts forever,
a friendship that nourishes you forever.
Things that you'll find that you'll keep
and treasure for a lifetime.
Hopefully this is one of those weekends.
It takes a lot of effort to learn.
It takes a lot of effort to grow.
It takes a lot of effort to decide,
debate,
but jot this down.
It's all worth the price.
Whatever stimulates you to think.
Whatever stimulates you to wonder.
Whatever stimulates you to react or even
to debate.
Even if you hear something,
you'd say,
well,
that's not right.
See,
that's still valuable.
It means you're awake.
It means you're alert.
It means you're alive.
It means your mind is ready to take on
something whether it's agreeable or not,
agreeable,
something right,
something wrong.
Who cares what it is?
We've got to listen to a variety of
voices and some are going to come from
the left and some are going to come from
the right and some are going to come
from mysterious sources and some will
try to entice you with all kinds of
stuff,
but that's okay.
Just so you're alive and alert and
awake,
ready to process anything that comes
your way,
take the best of it and make it
beneficial for you so that tomorrow you
walk with a stronger step.
Next month you see a clearer vision and
a month from now,
the purpose for your life is multiplied
by two,
three,
five.
That's what I want to create here,
so now to hurry and get through because
we have so many subjects to cover.
Let's cover now some other things under
personal development.
Here's one that's important.
As you read and as you listen to and as
you study and as you grow,
and as you take notes and as you fill up
your journal
and then try to work on the ideas to
make yourself valuable in the
marketplace.
Here's something to remember.
Under personal development,
some things I had to learn.
First steps to success.
First of all,
you need good ideas.
Just decide right now.
You're going to accelerate your plan for
collecting good ideas,
ideas for your life,
ideas for your health,
ideas for your marriage,
your relationships,
ideas that stimulate one idea sometimes
lead to that leads to the next leads to
the next
and the four or five ideas in the future
that really thrust acceleration into
your life.
You couldn't have gotten unless you went
through the first one and the second one
and the third one.
Next,
you need a good plan,
so we're going to talk about time
management and game plans tomorrow.
Need a good health plan traveling around
the world.
You can imagine the kind of health plan
I have to have if I didn't have a super
extreme.
Got An underline the word extreme.
If I didn't have a superb extreme health
plan,
you think I could travel all over the
world.
People look at my calendar and say,
you know possible.
I'm the only one that can do it.
Everyone else do young,
incredible,
but I've got to be extremely healthy.
I can't let up at all in terms of diet,
nutrition,
exercise,
all that stuff in order to stay healthy,
so a good health plan,
a good family plan.
Here's a good one,
a good marriage plan.
Some people just go along,
married,
but their fingers crossed.
You got to have a better plan than that
summer whistling in the dark,
hoping everything will work out.
Not Not a good plan.
You need a good plan for how to use the
day.
We'll talk about that tomorrow.
Best kept secret of the rich,
how to use your time,
a good plan to meet the right people
over the right amount of time to
stimulate your life.
You need a game plan for lifestyle.
We'll talk about that later.
So to succeed,
we need good ideas and good plans.
Here's the next.
We have to learn to handle the passing
of time
because all of this takes time to learn,
to grow,
to change.
Getting through the seasons takes time.
The spring has a certain amount of time,
the summer as time harvest has time.
The winter has time.
Learning to handle the passing of time
dot this down.
If you're involved in business,
you've got to give your project time.
You've got to give people time.
Give people a chance to learn,
chance to grow,
chance to change.
One of the great requirements,
especially in such an industrialized,
busy,
mad dashing society and that is to have
people,
patients first,
we exercise it with our children or our
family.
Getting people to work together,
got to have patience.
Even with your family,
if you're involved with independent
people,
it's a challenge.
It's like herding cats,
trying to get them to work together.
Herding sheep as easy.
They very quickly get going the same
direction,
but try herding cats.
It's like your children.
Different ages and different
personalities and different opinions to
get the family all going the same
direction.
Kind of working together to make things
work.
I'm telling you,
it is a challenge,
but if you'll have some patients,
you can do it.
Now,
here's the big one,
to have patience with yourself.
Give yourself time to learn.
Give yourself time to understand good
ideas.
Give yourself time to make changes and
then grow into those changes.
Give yourself time to refine your
personality,
to fit the business.
Whatever business you're engaged in,
some you may have to speak up a little
stronger and some you may have to calm
down just a little bit more.
Just learn to refine your personality
and your temperament to suit.
All of us could do that,
but it takes it takes time.
Have patience with yourself.
We had to do that from the beginning.
Learning to tie the shoe strings of your
shoes.
If you tried a couple of times and says,
I'll never learn this,
it's overseen.
No,
you can't go through life with your
shoe's untied.
Come on.
Some people,
maybe it happens for them in a little
quicker than others.
Some people get the hang of it almost
overnight.
Someone else that takes a little longer.
If it takes you a little longer,
have patience with yourself because
patients has its own reward.
Patience is a virtue of the
extraordinary kind.
We have to have patience with our
employers.
We have to have patients with government
officials.
You've got to have patients with irs.
You've got to have patience with the
army.
FBI.
Here's a good thing to remember.
While you're exercising patients,
usually enough,
good people will finally make it right.
You just got to jot that down.
Usually enough,
good people will finally make it right.
Not everyone in the community is going
to toe the line and do the moral thing,
but let me tell you what most will.
That's how we create a society that we
can live in.
Most will.
Every teenager will not obey all the
rules and regulations and live a model
life.
Not everyone will,
but jot this down.
Most will enough will.
When the good Lord recruited 12,
not every disciple,
not every one of the 12,
but it was enough of the 12 to start a
movement that's lasted for 2000 years.
Not everyone,
but
enough.
There's only been a couple of exceptions
to that.
Rule.
One was the story of Sodom and Gomorrah.
God was going to destroy Sodom and
Gomorrah for their evil ways.
Abraham had a friend that lived there
and Abraham and Florida and said,
God,
if I can go to Sodom and Gomorrah and
find 50 righteous people,
will you spare the city?
And God said,
Abraham,
you've been such an excellent friend of
mine.
Yes,
I'll spare the city if you can find 50.
So he searches the city,
can't find 50 good,
comes back and says,
lowered.
Would you take 40
gods as Abraham for you?
Come on,
I'll do it if you can find 40.
So we searches for 40,
can't find 40.
And he comes back and says,
would you take 30?
Good Lord says Abraham only for you.
Will I reduce it to 30?
Can't find 30,
can't find 20.
Abraham said,
this is my last request.
Would you take 10?
God said only for you Abraham.
So he went searching for 10 and you
know,
the story couldn't find 10.
That's the exception to the rule.
So we said,
Abraham,
get your friend lot and his family out
of there because the end has gone,
but that's the exception to the rule.
So jot down the general rule.
Most will in a civilized society,
most will obey the rules in government.
Most will,
not every senator will,
but what enough will to build a stable
government and a future.
Not everyone in the armed forces will,
but enough will.
Not everyone in the community will,
but enough with not every teenager in
this high school,
we'll,
but I'm telling you the most will and
that's how we survive in a civilized
society because most will.
And that's a good feeling to know most
wheel
okay?
So have patience.
Next,
under personal development is learning
to solve problems.
By the way,
having patients with the seasons takes
time to develop the crop.
You can't plant the seed,
dig around it in a few days saying,
where is it?
Where is it?
And you can't really help.
All you can do is nourish.
Some people planted spring,
leaving the summer,
just haven't got the patience to last.
So next comes solving problems,
business problems,
family problems,
personal problems,
financial problems,
emotional problems.
There's all kinds.
Here's a good idea.
I found in solving problems every once
in a while.
You've got to.
I've got it here,
but I can just describe it before you
take a piece of paper.
Put a line down the center of the paper,
and on the left side describe the
problem.
So just jot that down on a piece of
paper in half on the left side,
described the problem.
Sometimes it's a good idea to take a
problem out of your head and put it on
paper.
We'll talk a little bit more tomorrow
about how to think on paper.
This is one of the ways to think on
paper.
Our mind usually is too busy sometimes
to sort things out.
So if you take it out of your mind,
put it on paper,
what is the problem and you to describe
to the of your ability what the problem
is and then ask this question,
is that all of it?
Because if you're going to prescribe
something for the problem,
you need to know what all of the is.
When you've got it all listed on the
other side,
now of the paper's called answers and
solutions,
the problem on one side,
answers and solutions on the other side,
and now let me give you three questions,
three questions that can help solve
almost any problem.
Here are those questions.
Number one,
what could I do?
So just jot that down.
What can I do?
Then you start developing what we call
working papers and the working papers
consist of making a list of the things
you could do to solve this problem.
Number one,
and you say,
well,
number one would take too long.
I can see that right now.
Let's go to number two.
Maybe that's the answer.
Number three,
no,
that isn't it,
and let's say you've got several points
now and you've done your best to try to
solve the problem yourself and you can't
solve it yourself.
Here's the second question.
What could I read?
Maybe somebody spent a lifetime
researching the problem you've got and
they've got some excellent answers from
a lifetime of research.
Maybe in your own journal,
you've taken notes before on something
you say,
Hey,
I remember a class site took.
Seems like there were some answers
there,
so you go back,
do a little research,
so under number two is research and if
you search what you will find if you
research,
you will find search and research.
Now research as soon as possible because
of the problem is severe.
You don't want to wait until too late.
My friend Kenny comes to me and says,
you just lost a beautiful lady,
fabulous lady.
They got a divorce.
She was really something.
Then after his divorce,
he comes to me and says,
you know it's over,
but he says,
you know something strange.
He said,
I found a book in my library that I
think would have saved my marriage if I
had read it before my divorce
and it was a book entitled how to live
with another person.
He said,
I should've read that book a long time
ago.
He finally read it,
but it was a little late.
It's like reading a book on nutrition
after you've had a heart attack.
Right.
To me,
that's good.
That is good,
like gosh,
it's so much better to read it before.
Spare yourself the agony and the last
time and maybe the loss of your life.
Now,
if you,
if you tried to solve it yourself and
you can't solve it and you've researched
and it doesn't seem like you've got the
answer.
Here's number three.
The third question is who could I ask?
Is there someone around me that might
have the answer to my
problem
now under that,
but here,
but this.
Don't ask first.
No.
Try to solve it yourself.
Develop some working papers.
What you think you might do that still
isn't it?
Here's some books I've read.
This guy's crazy.
This guy,
no answers,
haven't got it now I asked,
but if you now can show your working
papers to who you asked,
you can't believe how swift the answer
will come.
All of us have heard this,
but let's remind ourselves one more time
and put it in your notes.
We all love to help people who first of
all try to help themselves.
Back to the philosophy of deserve.
I've tried to work it out.
I haven't got the answer.
Maybe you can help me.
Somebody is very willing to help you if
they know you've tried first to help
yourself.
It works that way with our children.
Right.
My daughter,
Linda,
before she got married,
I used to travel a lot.
She comes to me and say,
Daddy,
I'm headed for Thailand.
I said,
wonderful.
She said,
I've saved up my money.
I said,
fantastic.
She said,
I've got a thousand dollars.
I said,
wonderful.
She said,
the kids wanted to go here.
I wanted to go there.
I didn't go.
They wanted to buy this one,
buy that I didn't buy.
I got my money.
Put aside a thousand dollars.
I said,
Linda,
unbelievable.
You must be my daughter.
That's fantastic.
Now she said,
to make the trip,
I only need a couple of thousand dollars
more.
An easy 2000.
Right?
But she knew she couldn't get the whole
three,
but she knew that if she worked hard to
the best of her ability and put that
first thousand together,
then next to is easy.
Right?
Okay.
So develop your working papers.
Do your best to solve problems.
Here's why you try to solve it on your
own.
First you need the mental and emotional
muscle.
You need the discipline.
If you just quickly go to the answer,
somebody that's got it,
now you're not developing the muscle.
You're not developing the discipline to
solve your own problems because there
may come a day when there's no one else
to ask,
so you need the rhythm of learning,
the rhythm of trying,
the rhythm of seeing if you can do it
first to build the emotional mental
muscle.
Okay?